hi I'm Erik Bosse and we just got our
first look at the Wonder Woman sequel
titled Wonder Woman 1984 two interesting
photos were released along with the
movie's title establishing the movie in
the year 1984 during the Reagan years in
the Cold War surprisingly there's a lot
to unpack from these images and some
details that you might have missed so
let's look closely at them and break it
all down the first image was released by
director patty Jenkins who is returning
to direct the sequel it shows Steve
Trevor Chris Pine yeah this is odd
because Steve Trevor definitely appeared
to die in a plane explosion at the end
of the first movie which was set in
World War 1 nearly 70 years before this
sequel is set so how is he alive why
hasn't he aged at all now it makes sense
that Diana wouldn't have aged much
during this time jump she is an
amazonian of the mascara daughter of
Zeus and she was apparently close to 800
years old during the first one a woman
movie Trevor is another story surviving
a plane death in a world war and waking
up the same age 70 years later haven't
we already seen a captain do that maybe
Trevor's life could have been spared
through some divine intervention
like Zeus pulling them up from the
underworld or magic this movie's working
title is Magic Hour
maybe that's connected somehow or or
maybe we're looking at Trevor's grandson
who just looks a lot like him I kind of
like the theory that Trevor could be
some kind of spirit guide who's just in
Diana's mind that could explain why his
wardrobe is so stereotypically a tease
like he's wearing a Members Only jacket
it's a youngster style also some other
set photos feature him wearing a fanny
pack oh by the way in that photo Diana's
wardrobe with the white collar and blue
pinstripe vest in a bass jacket is a nod
to an outfit worn by Lynda Carter on the
original Wonder Woman TV series but when
it comes to Steve it's a little hard to
tell sometimes the difference in 80s TV
shows and movies between characters
wearing the type of clothes that people
actually wore day to day in the 80s or
when it's kind of a parody of those
times like an 80s themed prom night
there are also some rumors that Cersei
might be a villain in the sequel and
she's a character with magical powers
that could produce some kind of mind
trick on Diana but we have learned that
cheetah will be a villain in the movie
played by Kristen Wiig whatever is going
on here Steve Trevor definitely looks
like a fish out of water look at the
background that is a shopping mall
there's another thing that had its
heyday in the 80
that's becoming less and less common
nowadays thanks Amazon just kidding I
think it's clear we don't go there
because of the kids Steve Trevor's kind
of a reverse Marty McFly here he's a guy
wandering in a strange new time but
instead of an 80s kid who's confused in
the 50s Trevor is a nineteen teens guy
confused in the 80s he also appears to
be walking into an ice cream shop which
could be setting up a callback to the
ice cream scene in the first movie you
should be very proud let's move on to
the other photo released by gal gadot
herself showing Diana in front of a
bunch of TV monitors if you look closely
at these screens several of them feature
references to 80s pop culture on the
left is the character jr. Ewing played
by Larry Hagman on the TV series Dallas
in the 80s he was the villainous
character who was shot leading to the
who shot JR phenomenon then to Diana's
left you can see Christie Brinkley from
national lampoon's vacation in the scene
where she drove the red Ferrari
alongside Clark Griswold during the road
trip the others are a bit harder to
identify specifically initially that the
upper one could be from the Duran Duran
Rio music video or maybe something from
robbing Leech's lifestyles of the rich
and famous and the jet beside it I
thought could be from Top Gun but that
actually came out in 1986 two years
after this movie set and then in the
bottom right looks like something from
the 1980s cola wars where Pepsi and Coke
were at each other's necks with a new
splashy commercials perhaps this could
be something from the Michael Jackson
Pepsi commercials and then to the left
of it is something with a mohawk
probably from some eighties punk music
video overall I'm not sure if this image
of Diana is actually from the movie it
could just be something to promote the
fact that the sequel is set in the 80s
really I'm saying that because I don't
know why Diana would be so mystified
here remember the ending of Wonder Woman
left her fighting crime in man's world
she would have seen how human technology
and culture would evolve firsthand
instead of this look of shock like she's
Daryl Hannah's character from splash or
Milla Jovovich from the Fifth Element
some people are comparing this shot of
Diana to the images of Adrian Veidt
Ozymandias from The Watchmen or Batman
and Lucius Fox in the Dark Knight or the
architect and the Matrix Reloaded
honestly the image of a character in
front of a ton of screens so many
different stuff and show up in a lot of
movies but to some people it's
suggesting that Diana may be facing some
kind of technology-based threat like
perhaps the villain dr. cyber from the
Wonder Woman comics dr. cyber is known
for having an armored suit that enhances
abilities and recent versions of the
character have made her an AI type being
that can hack any technology perhaps
making her a threat to ICBM technologies
during the Cold War really as we wait
for a trailer to come out and to clear
up some of this stuff in the movie
itself to debut in November 2019
Equestria did die in the plane and now
we're just seeing him reanimated or
brought back in some way here or do you
think he's somehow escaped and
parachuted to safety comment with your
thoughts and theories down below or
tweet me directly I da vas and follow
new rockstars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like and share this video and
subscribing to rock stars for deep dives
into the DC Cinematic Universe we did a
full breakdown of Wonder Woman when it
came out last year and Justice League
and we'll have some stuff coming out
soon about Aquaman and a look back at
the Nolan Batman trilogy look we know
Marvel's been hogging the dance floor
and you DC fans have been stuck over by
the punch bowl but don't worry your
songs coming up we got you here at new
rockstars so stay tuned and thanks for
watching this video bye